I'm doing well I think for the most part
you know there's good days and there's
bad days Shannon Doherty shares
heartbreaking news about her stage four
breast cancer the actress revealed the
cancer has spread to her brain sharing
this video to Instagram taken in January
from her first round of radiation she
says my fear is obvious everybody's
terminal I might live A lot longer than
somebody who's perfectly healthy you
have no idea Shannon goes on to know
that she's extremely claustrophobic
telling her 2 million followers that
fear and turmoil are what cancer can
look like the original reason why I
chose to share the diagnosis was it was
going to come up anyway and it is my
story so I'm sharing in order to give
hopefully a different face
to to all of this how have you found the
support from the people around you my
friends are my family right and
you know obviously you know how
supportive that you've been her pal
Sarah Michelle Geller showing that same
support on Wednesday reminding Shannon
you are a warrior alongside more stars
like Salma Blair who's wishing Shannon
finds peace and the actresses Mall Rats
director Kevin Smith calls her a
Fearless biter when she shaved her head
that's when things got serious I'm in
awe of anybody's strength when they have
to face the unknown you appreciate the
genius of somebody who's facing the
unfaceable
Shannon's cancer went into her mission
in 2017 two years after sharing Her
diagnosis but she announced in 2020 that
it had returned and it was stage four
it's a bitter pill to swallow in a lot
of ways I would say that my first
reaction is always concerned about how
am I going to tell
my mom my husband you just stick
together and get through it the
emotional post this week comes two
months after another bombshell from
Shannon she announced she filed to
divorce her husband of 11 years Kurt is
waryanko going through the Journey with
her seeing seeing what's around the
corner tomorrow you know
a rep told ET at the time quote she felt
she was left with no other option he's
like we're gonna get through this we're
gonna get through it as a family
hours after news broke Shannon posted
the only people who deserve to be in
your life are the ones who treat you
with love kindness and total respect
sharing my story and being so sort of
open and honest it helped me I'm very
blessed of course Shannon's also been
quick to point out that her work ethic
hasn't slowed amid her health Journey
work is so important to me and
especially
as as somebody with cancer you want to
constantly put it out there that you
know you're still horrible you're so
employable and and then oftentimes for
people like like myself it's the work
that helps
drive us you know it's it's the work
that like I wake up in the morning so
excited to go create and do my job which
is a job that I actually love
[Music]